à trinité c'est pour des raisons de
sécurité que les femmes enceintes ne
seront plus prises en charge à compter
de demain matin
en temps normal trois médecins
anesthésistes se relaie à l'hôpital mais
deux sont actuellement en arrêt et la
troisième en congé pas question donc
d'accueillir les futures mamans car une
urgence poserait un risque vital pour
elle comme pour l'enfant
nous pouvons être quand même confronté à
une patiente qui saignent ou pour
laquelle l'enfant est en grande
souffrance foetale
donc sachant que c'est une question de
vie ou de mort pour la mère ou l'enfant
donc ça peut quand même être
préjudiciable le temps du transfert pour
moi c'est une situation qui juste
inimaginable et inacceptable puisque que
l'on veuille ou pas la population
en tout cas en situation d'urgence
extrême et des six points au compteur
dans un communiqué la direction du chum
assure faire tout son possible pour
revenir ou plutôt un fonctionnement
normal mais les appels aux médecins
anesthésistes de l'extérieur ou aux
volontaires de pierre zobda-quitman ne
sont guère entendu entre temps d'autres
services seront bien sûr perturber son
possibilité d'opérer les urgences bien
sûr et l'unité de soins intensifs et
toutes les chirurgies programmé du lundi
16 au 29 septembre sont supprimés on ne
comprend pas que l'on puisse des
programmes et ainsi d intervention
comprends pas qu'on rentre dans un dans
une crise exceptionnelle
o des effectifs qu'on devrait avoir donc
c'est cette situation là que le
personnel dénonce que l'ensemble du
personnel ne comprend pas puisque c'est
récurrent au niveau du chum on a eu le
problème avec les pédiatres
on a déjà eu on a des problèmes avec la
gériatrie a pas suffisamment de
gériatres donc on a l'impression qu'on
est en train de nous étouffer au fur et
à mesure le personnel prévoit de
débrayer lundi matin dans un centre
hospitalier comme celui du lorrain le
bloc devrait être opérationnel 24 heures
sur 24